i know you're interested in longevity
what do you do to try to live longer i
deeply believe that over the next
20 years plus minus we gonna slow down
hold and ultimately actually reverse
aging uh and that's going to happen why
because we have already and david is a
very good friend working with him yeah
we have already understood
what aging is
it's a complex disease it's not just one
disease like
another colleague of mine uh emmanuel
serrano uh coined this term like there
is these nine hallmarks of aging yeah
these are nine
ryan
nine thematic things which go
practically wrong but like i think
humanity has one great track record
always when we have realized and
understood a problem someone we're going
to solve it and i'm going to think
there's somewhere going to happen the
next 20 years so what i'm sobbing for
with my nutrition plan
is that i'm not dying the next 20 years
because i do think dying in the next 20
years is the most stupid time to die
yeah and it sounds actually like like
i'm 43 now so i most likely
statistically i'm here in 20 years but
it's not a 100 given if i would talk to
my 10 year old godson he doesn't need to
worry he's going to be there anyway
unless he has an accident yeah but like
with 43 yeah there is sort of a risk
that whatever actually there is two
risks there is uh if if i don't have
cancer in the next 20 years and if i
don't have a cardiovascular disease and
if i don't have an accident yeah but
these three things then very very likely
i'm going to be here so my whole diet
and intake of of therapeutics yeah is
focused on not getting cancer not
getting a cardiovascular disease being
here in 20 years roundabout when the
real stuff sort of comes because then i
think the game is on because like people
always think like oh
when somebody says and i deeply believe
that we can live for some hundred years
and i do think we here in the room will
live or have the opportunity to live for
some hundred years it's not gonna happen
from one day to the other there won't be
one magic pill
where we say okay now we take it and now
we live till 300 years but it's gonna be
a gradual shift yeah and there is this
famous thing like one day we're gonna
win more years per year than the one
year we lose and that's then sort of the
point when sort of
optionality is on and and by the way
also i do believe we don't want to live
forever because people interestingly i
just want to mention maybe not in this
sort of crowd but like i actually was on
holiday with friends and there once said
like oh no like this is sort of
not right and i was like hey a i do
think we don't want to live forever
forever is really long term yeah but i i
think it's the ultimate liberation
for humanity yeah
and sort of it fills in my libertarian
fuse that you decide yourself
when you want to end this yeah so i'm
you think people are going to do that
yes i mean i'm very sure you think
people are going to have the ability to
live forever and one day they're like
all right man
forever never going to happen because
someone in the earth is going to like
there is always an accident risk and if
you play it out long enough
statistically you're going to apply this
is what people came here to listen to so
here's here's i got a couple questions
if you survive for the next 20 years
right you're kind of in your early 40s
you'd be early 60s
at that point we've really started to
kind of hit the exponential growth of uh
we're gaining more years than we are
losing on a 12-month period
how far can we go if let's say we're at
80 on average right now globally for
average life expectancy can we get it to
hundred in the next 20 years can we get
it to 200 like just how much i think
it's life in the next 20 years by the
next 20 years i think we're gonna go
over a hundred yeah um i think there is
there is three um
sort of sweeney that's a big jump so we
did the math like what would happen
if if we solve cancer yeah and
interestingly statistically this would
add i think the number we came up with
was around about three years just
because people think oh we solve cancer
we're gonna live
ten years longer but then somebody
something else hits you that's actually
the the fickle thing with aging yeah if
you solve one thing you're gonna have a
stroke where you're gonna have so you
need to solve these are these nine
hallmarks of aging you need to solve
many problems at once but i think it's
solvable so then the first the one
question we're going to encounter which
nobody has to really answer we have a
hunch is that is there a natural limit
yeah so my view is like let's just test
it out like i'm happy if we go towards
hundred because there are some
scientists who think like okay there
might be like sort of kind of a natural
limit of 100 110 and when you reach that
even if you don't till actually till 100
or at the moment till these 80 years or
whatever people normally die of
something they don't die of exhaustion
they die of cancer whatever so let's
assume we can eliminate all of that yeah
so then there is one theory to be tested
yeah do we die of sort of exhaustion
like a car which just doesn't run
anymore without having one single thing
if that's the case okay at least we
gained 30 more years by the way i think
that's my view on everything in life why
not try like i'm an uber optimist and if
if people laugh at me or love about me
in 50 years and say okay there was this
dreamer who thought we can add hundreds
of years and he added with his work 10
years i'm like well it's [ __ ] amazing
i added 10 years to uh to humanity's
lifespan like so let's gradually work on
that so then the second big question is
do we stay
um a body-based species
or can we someone
change that so what does that mean well
there is one idea so there's two ideas
how you can look at longevity the one is
like we're going to repair
the body we have yeah or even prevented
someone from aging because we completely
control yeah
with
whatever crisper many we have so many
new intervention mechanisms in
in sort of life yeah that that there is
the possibility that we kind of control
our body and our mind in a way or
control like keep it functioning that
we're gonna be a body-based
species yeah and are happy with it
because we can repair the body all the
time replace stuff whatever and by the
way so then then you have the other
extreme view can we someone get rid of
our body just take what is actually
defining what is
what is pump what is christian like our
mind yeah whatever that that means and
our soul yeah and upload that into
a computer or any other structure so get
rid of the body which is the part which
is aging and decaying yeah and then
there is the the opportunity the
possibility in between which is i think
where it's going yeah that you sort of
merge
with technology which by the way we do
already now if you have a what's the
english term if you have a pacemaker
yeah you are a mini cyborg yeah we're
just very used to a pacemaker yeah uh
you have other people have replacement
hips exactly so yeah so just think that
50 years ahead maybe we just replace
whole body parts with technology but
still stay kind of in this world but the
value of my next 20 years is incredibly
more higher than it was for the same
person 100 years ago because yeah there
it was just 20 years if i do a mistake
in the next 20 years i may be
giving up hundreds of years and by the
way i'm so excited i always can say that
like about where the world is going i
know we so many people turn pessimistic
and we always because the media is
always focusing on the negative stuff
but like
everything i see in our portfolio beyond
that is is [ __ ] cool stuff yeah and i
want to by the way he won't go on the
autobahn because car accidents are one
of the numbers
the question would be like where does
that risk tolerance like where is the
barrier
i'm always reassessing it it's like you
could obviously say if i stay at home
and do nothing yeah that would be the
best because you can have a plane
accident so i do think because i love
life yeah it's not that i sort of i'm
not afraid of that stuff but i i just
want to enjoy life and all the
innovation which is coming yeah and in
partly which i'm helping building yeah i
want to enjoy it and want to be there
when the real stuff comes when you think
of what you eat from a diet standpoint
what do you follow a speech yeah
diet so what is the main things the main
thing is actually what you said like
intermittent fasting so i haven't eaten
anything today so i'm doing 18 hours
with zero calorie intake just water
and and black coffee but no no calorie
intake yeah which is by the way you any
form of fasting is great that's just the
fasting which works for me in sort of my
daily rhythm like other people do five
day fasting and then eat normally so i
do like 16 to 18 hours no calorie intake
why
you said it it's counterintuitive but
like your body goes into like a laundry
mode you could say that way like sort of
it's flushing out senescent cells it's
really rejuvenating and it starts around
about hour 14 that you go into that sort
of state so so the longer actually you
can be if you could be sometimes i make
a full day yeah without food or without
anything that is actually ideal um i try
to need a lot of carbs
maybe the healthy ones lentils whatever
but not the bad ones carbs a pasta blah
blah
i actually take pitformin that is i
think sort of from the medical side the
most we know potent using metformin
metformin yeah which is actually a
diabetes drug but which seems to mimic
fasting and then there is a a newer
version which actually is interesting
because um i always have in psychedelics
with some people that discussion about
patterns like is it allowed to patent
psychedelic substances because it's
god's
givens things and i i think patterns are
inherently important for drug
development which we unfortunately see
with metformin because metformin is a
diabetes drug which is out of pattern
it's super cheap so there are great
studies but not fda studies so more like
looking at people who take metformin how
they
how they age whatever which suggests
that metformin is incredibly healthy but
no pharma company is putting the money
up to prove it in an fda-like framework
because they can't make money with it so
it would be great if metformin is in
patent again because people would then
hopefully prove it like
somebody did it novo nordisk has a drug
called ozempeg which is also a diabetes
drug so it shows by the way that it
seems to be that so when you take
metformin what does it do
so it's kind of
in a non-medical way it's mimicking
fasting yeah it's controlling your
insulin spike and that whole world of
taking food especially sugar or
sugar-like foods yeah which makes your
insulin spike whatever that seems to
over the course of our life be one of
the drivers for inflammation
you